Thirty-six years since high-flying
speedster Maverick first rocketed
across the big screen, he's back.
But will the sequel take your breath
away or is it writing checks it can't cash?
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm comparing Top Gun: Maverick to the
80s original, revealing the biggest differences
and whether it's a worthy sequel.
Some spoilers ahead, so take care.
Since Tom Cruise last slipped on
those aviators, a lot has changed.
Top Gun took the young actor born on the
3rd of July 1962 and made him a huge star,
and at nearly 60 years of age he's back to show he
can still 'turn and burn' with the best of them,
including those almost half his age.
I can hold my own.
And like his character, Maverick, the
American made mega-star actor seems
happiest when he's going Mach 2 with his
hair on fire, except in the new movie he
actually gets to go way faster than that!
Though Maverick decided to become a Top Gun
instructor in 1986,
God help us.
...we find out he only did
that for a couple of months.
And as he wanted to keep flying,
satisfying his need for speed,
rather than rising through the navy ranks,
You should be at least a two-star admiral by now.
Yet here you are, captain.
he's now a test pilot until he gets called back
to Top Gun for some intense training, teaching
a new crop of graduates his 'inverted' ways.
Everyone here is the best there is.
Who the hell are they going to get to teach us?
And while he certainly still
has his rebellious side,
he's not quite as hot-headed
or focused on himself as he
once was:
Woo!
That's what I'm talking about!
It's not your flying, it's your attitude.
Sure, he was already stepping up by the end of
the original, but now time's passed and he's
grown up and more into his responsibilities.
Though he died in the first film, Nick Bradshaw
aka Goose pops up in flashback memories
and photos showing how Maverick is still
tormented by his best friend's death.
And Goose lives on in his son, Bradley,
aka Rooster, who popped up briefly as a child back
in the 1986 movie, and is now a Top Gun pilot.
Rooster's a chip off the old block:
there's that moustache and hair, the Hawaiian
shirt, and he sings Great Balls of Fire at the
piano, which apparently Miles Teller learnt
for the movie and plays for real.
Obviously, given their history,
Maverick's relationship with Rooster is
more complicated than it was with Goose.
Expect lots of drama, including
a heady mix of resentment,
guilt, and a barrelful of tension between them.
Plus, his father's fate means both that Rooster
can be a bit more cautious flying compared
to other pilots, and that Maverick wants
to look out for him, like a father figure.
Maverick's old nemesis Iceman is now an admiral,
and is crucial to the plot as he insists on
Mav being posted back to Top Gun to train its
graduates for a complex special mission.
You are here at the request of Iceman.
He seems to think you have
something left to offer the Navy.
Actor Val Kilmer returns in a short but
touching cameo which sees the friends
and former rivals discuss the dangerous
new operation and their shared past.
Much of Iceman's side of the conversation
is tapped out on a computer as Kilmer's
real-life experience with throat cancer
is woven into his character's story.
The whole scene is particularly
poignant, especially for fans who
grew up watching the original film.
You can be my wingman anytime.
You can be mine.
As for the spirit of the young
1980s Iceman, that lives on in Hangman, a cocky
new Top Gun graduate, played by Glenn Powell,
What do we have here?
And here I thought we were special.
Fellas, this here's Bagman.
Hangman
whose hostility towards Rooster has definite
shades of Iceman and Maverick back in the day,
with a neat twist on the 80s plot.
While Val Kilmer returns in person and a
young Anthony Edwards and his on-screen wife Meg
Ryan return in flashbacks, the original film's
female lead, astrophysicist and Top Gun civilian
contractor Charlie, played by Kelly McGillis,
isn't even name-dropped in passing, despite
her and Maverick ending up together.
Instead, Cruise's on-screen love
interest this time is Penny Benjamin,
owner of aviators' club The Hard Deck, who
was briefly mentioned in the first movie,
Well, there was the time...
Admiral's daughter.
He told me all about the time you
went ballistic with Penny Benjamin.
...and is now brought to
life by Jennifer Connelly.
While there was no previous history between
Charlie and Maverick when they kicked off
their romance back in the 80s, Penny and
Maverick's relationship has been on and
off many times over the years but maybe now
it's time to fly off into the sunset.
Both military and movie technology's
come a long way since the mid-80s
and that's clearly reflected in the sequel.
While for other movies that might mean stacks
of CGI sequences, this is a Tom Cruise production,
an actor who's not just known for his star power,
but also for his perfectionism and
penchant for old-school movie-making,
so the emphasis is very much on doing
as many practical stunts as possible.
In fact, Cruise who's famous for doing lots
of his own action, on land and in the air,
reportedly also took the time to create bespoke
aviation programmes for the movie's young cast,
who did several months of
intense flight training.
That meant that while the planes were flown
by real Navy pilots, the filmmakers were
able to shoot the young actors in the air
really reacting to 'the need for speed',
in other words the kind of stomach-churning
G-force they'd feel in real life.
The result is that often it feels as if you're in
the air with them soaring and diving through the
skies during the movie's plentiful scenes
of fast-paced aerobatics and dogfights,
which are exactly the kind of thing made to
be seen on the most massive screen available.
As well as the newer planes appearing in the
sequel, one of the main fighter aircrafts from
the 80s movie, the F-14 Tomcat, is back
in action, and also just like in the 80s,
the enemy remains nameless.
Understandably, given the first
film was introducing audiences to the world of the
Navy's Fighter Weapons School for the first time,
that movie focuses more on training
exercises for general missions and
in-fighting among students vying to be top dog.
However, the new film raises the stakes much
earlier on, with Maverick preparing the latest
batch of Top Gun graduates for a very specific,
almost impossible mission that
will see them zooming slap
bang into the middle of a real danger zone.
We're going into combat on a level no living
pilot's ever seen.
Not even him.
As well as all the 21st-century
twists on the original movie,
there's also a hefty hit of nostalgia in terms
of call-backs – from plot and character-driven
details to nods to Tony Scott's endless, stylish
sunset scenes and beach-side fun and games.
And, of course, is it even a Tom Cruise movie
without at least one scene of him running?
The superstar actor-producer also brings
together more than a few good men and
women both behind and in front of the
camera, creating a more diverse cast,
though as you'd expect it's Maverick who gets the
lions' share of screen time, followed by Rooster.
Of course, bringing back a character from long
ago, a legend who's the object of endless love,
is a very risky business with
plenty of potential for fallout.
For every movie that taps into that perfect
night-and-day cocktail of old and new,
providing something for both long-term
fans and the outsiders to the franchise,
there are many more that prove that
losin' it all is a very real possibility.
Big success requires making all the
right moves if you want to end up
far and away from falling into oblivion.
Now, Cruise once said he'd never go back
to Top Gun, but there'll be a lot of
fans today glad he changed his mind
as along with masses of action, the sequel
brings a good deal more humour and heart.
And, no pressure on the sequel, but the
original movie's iconic soundtrack is one of
the best-selling soundtrack albums of all time!
Mixing songs written for the film like Danger
Zone with classic tracks from artists such
as The Righteous Brothers and Otis Redding,
the 80s soundtrack also nabbed an Oscar and Golden
Globe for Berlin's romantic theme, Take My Breath
Away, and a Grammy for the Top Gun Anthem.
The new film also mixes old and new with the
likes of Kenny Loggins and David Bowie featuring
alongside the power ballad Hold My Hand, sung and
co-written by Lady Gaga, who's no stranger to
winning awards herself, and the same goes for
Hans Zimmer who scored the sequel along with
the original's composer Harold Faltermeyer.
As for Danger Zone, Tom Cruise insisted
the song had to be in the film as it
wouldn't be a Top Gun movie without it.
And thanks to this video's sponsor, NordVPN, you
can avoid ending up in the online danger zone.
Nord have just launched their new Threat
Protection feature which blocks
trackers, making your online experience
a lot cleaner, safer, and enjoyable.
So next time you accidentally stumble
across a shady site or a phishing link,
Nord's Threat Protection will neutralise
and destroy the threat like it's seeking out
an enemy jet, scanning any downloaded files
for malware and deleting them immediately.
On top of that, Nord encrypts your internet
connection and conceals your IP address, so
you can keep all your online activity private.
It stops your internet service provider
from knowing what websites you visit
and Nord's Threat Protection will also block those
third-party cookies that follow you around the web
bombarding you with incredibly intrusive ads.
With Nord, you can connect up to six devices
at any one time so you can protect all
your phones, laptops and computers.
For a limited time, all our viewers can
grab an exclusive offer on a 2-year plan
with a huge discount, plus a bonus month
and Threat Protection completely free.
Just visit NordVPN.com/Flicks or go to the link
in the video description to get the offer.
Or use coupon code FLICKS when you check out.
So, Movie Lovers, what do you think of the Top Gun
sequel and how does it compare to the original?
Let me know below.
And if you liked this video, do leave
a thumbs-up, I really appreciate it.
Next, tap left to discover the Doctor
Strange: Multiverse of Madness deleted
scenes that Marvel cut from the film.
Thanks for enjoying this movie with me and hope
you have a marvellous movie-loving week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!